‏o
[Silence]
‏tr
‏b
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله
[Silence]
استول الصلاه اثابكم
الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نع بد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ان ربك يعلم انك تقوم ادنى من ثلثي الليل
ونصفه وثلثه
وطائفه من الذين
معك والله يقدر الليل
والنهار علم ان لن تحصوه فتاب عليكم فاقرا
ما تيسر من
القران علم ان سيكون
منكم مرضى واخرون يضربون في
الارض واخرون يضربون في الارض واخرون
يقاتلون في سبيل الله
فاقرا ما تيسر منه واقيموا الصلاه واتوا
الزكاه واقرضوا الله قرضا
حسنا وما تقدموا
لانفسكم من
خير تجدوه عند
الله دوه عند الله هو خيرا واعظم
اجرا
واستغفر
الله ان الله غفور
رحيم الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر بسم الله
الرحمن الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
انا
انزلناه في ليله
القدر
وما ادراك ما ليله
القدر ليله القدر
خير من الف
شهر تنزل
الملائكه والروح فيها باذن
ربهم من كل
امر سلام هي حتى مطلع
الفجر الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
اللا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله لا اله الا الله
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
الله اكبر الله اكبر
و الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
الله الله اكبر الله اكبر ولله الحمد الله
اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا الله
والله اكبر الله اكبر ولله
[Silence]
الحمد بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
رب العالمين والصلاه
والس وعلى اله وصحبه ومن ولاه ومن تبع
باحسان ال يوم الدين اما بعد ان شاء الله
سقره الله
سبحان تكمل
العده ولتكمل ع ولتكبروا الله على ما
هداكم ولعلكم
تشكرون
الله
سالى
soare in incl and everybody
incl know me as always we all are
ingles the differ might be be different
other the struggle is same in world
الله سبحان
وتالد
الله make some el he does not
want for you does not want you to be
[Silence]
اللهى
تصلا المغ
الحد
لاهلاه
الجلا
back
[Silence]
‏every
‏take
[Silence]
‏days
21 is one the fruit even
sweet ‏extrem sweet ites not a gluc spik
in because fib in has fibber in it slows
down bl glucose abortion bl sugar
abortion in bl so it's not b for you but
anything in is b for you so you know
just one is f you it way these are the m
things be what is other important
[Silence]
‏it is a way
to
[Silence]
الله
تبلا
الجلاد
الله
شاء
question
about all
[Silence]
‏second
تبق
[Silence]
‏he said said look gu
i'll gu you have
times
‏there is a difference of opinion again
but خ
do there difference of
opinion all
right as
all i you sleeping
that
‏have
do i
give
toif
c
[Silence]
‏m
‏ex
[Silence]
‏reg
الله
حث عليهه
وسلامه
الر
صلاك
الركرد
reg
reg so
[Silence]
الله
‏not
take be mindful of and
friends there
people he about not you know me it's
you the mage
out ان شا
[Silence]
الله
الانال parad and he feed us parad
without any you accoun hees us
all ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا ع النار وقنا عب ربنا تقبل منك
ان السميع العليم وتب علينا يا مولانا
التواب الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى
اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك ارحم الرحمين
اللهم امين اللهم امين اللهم
[Silence]
امين
ا